it'll be a new experience that I've
never had before that I'm gonna learn
how to deal with and I think that's what
life's about Tom Brady's opening up
about his holiday plans prioritization I
think has been the key for me as I've
gotten older and this year he's spending
them without Gisele Bundchen and their
kids it gets harder and harder as you
get older because you do take on a lot
more in your life on his podcast let's
go with Tom Brady Larry Fitzgerald and
Jim Gray the athlete explains he'll be
spending Christmas in Arizona when the
Tampa Bay Bucks go head-to-head against
the Cardinals I'm going to learn how to
deal with Christmas Eve in a hotel and
I'm gonna have to learn how to deal with
Christmas on Christmas night and still
go out there and be a professional and
then look forward to celebrating
Christmas with my kids uh you know the
day after which is you know just part of
what
you know part of what football season
has been for a long time the holiday
away comes just two months two months
after Tom and Gisele announced they were
ending their marriage and I feel like
I'm so driven to succeed in football and
that's taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife the former couple shares
two kids Benjamin and Vivian Tom also
has a son John whom he shares with
ex-girlfriend Bridget Moynihan they're
just the biggest blessing at the time of
their split A source told ET that
Giselle was quote devastated to end
things with Tom everyone's got different
situations they're dealing with so we
all have really unique challenges to our
life and
you know we're
I'm 45 years old man there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on so you know you just gotta
try to figure out life the best you can
and it's a
continuous process ET also learned
giselle's been working with her healer
to come to terms with her divorce quote
Tom and Gisele have love for one another
but Giselle knew she had to put herself
and her family first over football she's
really held it down for our family and
I'm just super grateful that you know
she really committed so much of her time
the last you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream last month Tom
broke his silence on the split during a
chat on his podcast so the good news is
things it's a very amicable situation
and I'm really focused on two things and
taking care of my family
and certainly my children and secondly
doing the best job I can to win football
games so that's what professionals do
you focus at work when it's time to work
and then when you come home you focus on
the priorities that are at home the
football star also opened up about how
he's learned to balance his work and
home life I want to be a great father to
my children and always try to do things
the right way as well and
deal with things that in your life that
have challenges you want to deal with
the in the best possible way so I want
to always be able to hold my head high
on and off the field and I'm going to
try to continue to do that for as long
as I'm here
[Music]
foreign